so Fox is alert now we're tracking the
story the Acting Secretary the US Navy
offering to resign earlier today after
he fired the commander of the aircraft
carrier the USS Theodore Roosevelt the
commander had sounded the alarm about a
Copa 19 outbreak on board his ship
Lucas Tomlin's tracking the story from
the Pentagon now and Lucas how are we
tying this together at the moment well
bill good afternoon just moments ago I
learned not only did Acting Navy
secretary Thomas mode Lee offered to
resign he has resigned he's told his
staff so that means just a week ago
who's captain Bret Crozier the
commanding officer of the Theodore
Roosevelt was on the hot seat after a
letter a plea for help to top Navy brass
was leaked to his local newspaper in San
Francisco leading to his ouster on
Thursday by the acting Navy secretary
but within days the acting Navy
secretary himself was put on the hot
seat
Thomas muddly visited the aircraft
carrier himself on Monday flying all the
way halfway across the world to Guam in
the western Pacific where he addressed
the crew over the 1mc or the loudspeaker
that goes throughout the entire ship and
addressed all 5,000 members of the crew
where he offered her signed but within
days he realized he had done the wrong
thing he apologized and today he offered
his resignation bill
Lucas Thank You Lucas Tomlinson breaking
news on that more details when we get it